[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous ceux bonjour
serge arrive au bonjour bonjour à tous
les auditeurs et s'auto aux collègues
qui sont au chevet des patients et qui
font fonctionner toutes les structures
médico sociales et sanitaires de
martinique
vous êtes secrétaire général de l'ugtm
santé votre cheval de bataille depuis
quelque temps le cce hôpital de trinité
l'avenir de l'hôpital de trinité alors
dans cette lutte syndicale mais pas que
parce que le personnel politique ses
adjoints à vous on peut même dire que
c'est une lutte sociétal martiniquaise
peut-être même désormais on en a
l'impression où en est-on serge haribo
en ce 2 mars
avez vous de bonnes nouvelles des
engagements signe d'espoir a annoncé à
la population depuis le front où vous
vous trouvez on le rappelle un mouvement
de grève depuis la fin de l'année
dernière
depuis le 30 septembre 2020 et 100
serrano quatrième jour de grève et nous
considérons que nous avons déjà franchi
un certain nombre d'étapes mais l'étape
la plus cruciale la plus importante
c'est de faire comprendre à la direction
générale du chu de matinée qu'il y a
lieu de changer de façon de faire de
concevoir la distribution de l'offre de
soins sur le territoire et cette façon
de faire on n'a pas encore de réponse
probante
parce que on traîne des pieds sur 154
jours de grève nous n'avons eu que 25 e
rencontres de négociations ça vous
montre tout de même le manque de prise
en considération par la direction du
santos et de martinique
alors oui nous avançons parce que nous
avons réussi à faire en sorte que ce
problème ne soit pas simplement un
problème de centre hospitalier celui de
trinité en premier lieu c'est un
problème de d'offre de soins d'égalité
d'équité d'accès aux soins pour une
population de 100 mille habitants dans
le nord
le deuxième volet c'est la répartition
territoriale de ses troupes de soins qui
doit être égalitaire équitable aussi du
nord au sud de l'est à l'ouest la
martinique
et là aussi ce problème est posé parce
que nous avons tout de même réussi à
faire en sorte qu'il y ait une unité
d'action
que ce soit au niveau des mers des du
nord que ce soit au niveau des
parlementaires et que ce soit au niveau
des opci demartini espace sud kacem qui
soutiennent ce mouvement
donc nous considérons que oui nous
avançons et nous attendons une réponse
cette semaine de la part du ministère
concernant les investissements tout en
étant conscient peut-être que en face il
n'y a pas de baguette magique
en même temps il n'y a pas de baguette
magique mais il ya un sens moral à
donner à l'action administrative et en
respect des engagements de l'état qui
n'est pas et qui a qui s'est fourvoyé
dans le dossier de ma de du centre c
elui domergue mais ce n'est pas le seul
dossier en martinique depuis avril 2002
donc voyez nous sommes à 2021 ne cessant
de répéter qu'il y a lieu de respecter
le patient 2011 ça va faire 20 ans un
talent dont quasiment vingt ans et nous
espérons et nous avons la ferme
conviction que cette année nous allons
aboutir et nous ferons tout ce qu'il
faut qu'il faut pour aboutir donc oui il
y n conviction qu'il y a lieu de changer
cette façon de faire alors quand on dit
qu'il ya pas de l'argent je vous dis
simplement monsieur castex premier
ministre 2
du gouvernement annoncé une enveloppe de
400 millions d'euros pour le chu de
nantes qui représente 40% de la
reconstruction de ce chu soit une
opération d'un milliard d'euros
l'annoncé la ce il aurait pas dû faire
cette annonce là sans faire la noce
général du ségur puisqu'il s'agit de
remettre à l'ensemble des 22 rs de
france les volumes financiers pour des
opérations de ce type là donc on
favorise qui est-ce qui était premier
ministre avant mathieu castex qui est
maire de nantes aujourd'hui
donc oui à de l'argent il ya une
distribution équitable a à faire sur le
territoire alors de son côté la
direction du chu dit que l'ensemble des
alors je cite un communiqué un qui a été
produit par le la direction du chu au
moment même où vous étiez en mouvement à
l'hôpital pierre zobda-quitman il y a
quelques jours alors l'ensemble des
acteurs s'entendent pour considérer que
le projet de reconstruction de l'hôpital
louis domergue à trinité est prioritaire
à l'échelle du territoire nord mais in
fine et de toute la martinique estimé un
peu plus de 70 millions d'euros ce
projet a été priorisé par la rs dans le
cadre des projets qui seront financés
par le plan ségur des investissements en
santé
donc vous dites qu'en fait c'est pas
vraiment suivi pour le moment des faits
c'est pas suivies d'effet et ce sera
suivi d'effet cette année non seulement
sur les engagements qui étaient pris sur
la question de la réhabilitation la
sécurisation de la rénovation du centre
y de trinité nous avons un accord qui a
été acté par les inspecteurs généraux
qui étaient là en tant qu administrateur
provisoire en 2017 et qui ont opté pour
trinité un plan pluriannuel
d'investissement de 7 millions d'euros
pour les trois premières années il
fallait continuer en 2021 2022
ces 7 millions d'euros là on nous parle
de 3 millions d'euros donc cette
direction est fautive où sont passés les
4 millions d'euros sur les 7 millions
d'euros on n'a pas vu ses actions
concrètement on nous a laissés dans des
bâtiments ou est ce qu'il ya de l'eau
aujourd'hui s'il pleut il ya de l'eau
qui coule dans la plupart des bâtiments
nous n'avons pas professé dans ces
conditions là vous vous croyez la
pareille vos interlocuteurs
quand il est dit de 2021 donc voilà dès
cette année à 2023 des travaux de
modernisation
en attendant la reconstruction du
nouveau site des travaux de
modernisation du site actuel sont
programmés pour une enveloppe d'environ
13 millions d'euros pour ça c'est un
engagement alors en tout cas c'est écrit
c'est que nous soyons clairs la réalité
elle est là devant nous avons fait
l'effort d'aller devant toutes les
instances y compris la ctm nous avons
réussi à décrocher près de 15 millions
d'euros sur les fonds européens se sont
pas différents ni de l'état ni du chum
nous avons été dans des réunions à 18
heures alors que nous sommes sur des
piquets de grève depuis cinq heures du
matin et nous avons dit que le système
des rois fainéants doit s'arrêter
ces déclarations là elles ne sont pas
factuel nous disons que nous mettons
aujourd'hui dans l' enveloppe devant
toute la population martiniquaise 16
millions d'euros obtenus sur les fonds
européens pour certaines opérations de
rénovation par contre la direction du
chum à 28 millions du route d'état après
l'incendié du chu de martinique à sa
disposition
la leur ou est-ce que je parle n'ont
utilisé que 3 millions d'euros après 310
en guadeloupe en guadeloupe il
s'agissait de sécuriser les
établissements de santé en martinique et
particulièrement le chum
la direction de la rs depuis novembre
2020 indiqué à la direction du chu de
nantes in qu'elles pouvaient utiliser
sur ces 28 millions d'euros pour
finaliser l'ensemble des opérations de
rénovation de réhabilitation
la direction du chu de meetings ne nous
a jamais informé alors qu'elle a reçu ce
courrier nous étions négociations sur
ces points là et ce n'est qu'il ya une
quinzaine de jours lorsque nous avons
été le 10 février à la rs avec les
l'ensemble des politiques que le
directeur général de la grèce nous
informe de cela nous avons perdu trois
mois de discussions dont consomme vous
dit
bon il ya quelques engagements mais
attention on reste vigilant et attention
un peu à la poudre aux yeux en quelque
sorte si je comprends bien votre ya deux
méthodes qui va que tout le monde va
être bien comprendre nous pas l'élève
pourra malok mal papaye mal papaye pas
capoter
et deuxième chose que nous avons dit
dans cette mobilisation c'est soit on
arrêtait doubout de soi donc amour alors
justement est ce qu'il ya un front
syndical unitaire dans cette affaire là
parce qu'on a l'impression que alors
l'ugtm a initié depuis longtemps on l'a
dit mais est-ce que d'autres syndicats
vous appuyez mais s'affiche dans cet
appui il s'agit aujourd'hui parce que là
l'union ferait encore plus de force
en l'occurrence il s'agit pour
l'ensemble des interlocuteurs nous
l'avons nous avons fait une réunion la
semaine dernière avec on nous avons
invité l'ensemble des centrales
syndicales
mais d'autres langages est totalement
différent nous ne voulons plus que de
gens qui nous disent on vous soutient
nous avons dit il eu le même langage
avant de rentrer en grève avec cap nord
avec l'ensemble des maires pour leur
dire l'émotion le nassau 18 communes de
cap nord d'émotion qui date depuis les
années 2000
donc aujourd'hui nous demandons à chacun
à leur niveau de responsabilité de
prendre l'entière responsabilité qui
leur appartient on ne va pas prendre de
responsabilité âpre à la à la place des
autres
par contre ce que nous disons simplement
nous sommes en responsabilité dans ce
mouvement
et si d'aucuns n'a pas compris cela
je crois qu'il y à matière encore à
travailler la conscience à travailler
encore la compréhension des choses
nous sommes en responsabilité nous
prônons ray de nos responsabilités tout
un chacun qui veut être en
responsabilité avec nous nous n'avons
aucun problème même été court bien parce
que combattent à ses parents combat
authier ans après anjou ou grand il est
beau caillou alors avec la direction du
chu est ce que au delà de la situation
de l'hôpital de trinité de l'offre de
soins sur sûre pour le désert médical
que constitue encore le nord de l'île
est-ce que vous parlez de la situation
globale des hôpitaux publics parce qu'on
a l'impression qui a encore du pain sur
la planche là dessus et puis surtout que
ça donne finalement je dirais une santé
enfin des soins à deux vitesses on va
dire
les lanciers à la clinique où ceux qui
ont les moyens de se payer un billet
d'avion pour aller se soigner ailleurs
bon bah c'est bien et puis les plus
démunis dans des hôpitaux de faits de
bric et de broc quoi alors nous avons
introduit dans ce processus
cette compréhension qu'il y a lieu de
regarder globalement sur le territoire
l'exemple de ce mouvement de cette
compréhension de mettre en place sur le
territoire du nord les moyens qu'il faut
c'est de simplement comprendre lorsque
vous sortez de grand rivière pour
arriver au robert dénombrer le nombre de
pédiatres à votre disposition des
nombrils nombre de talmont log à votre
disposition dénombrer le nombre de
gastro entérologue en martinique les
garçons théologue on compte sur les deux
mains à la fin de l'année il restera
moins de 10 à disposition là où est ce
que nous avons été plus loin que des
revendications
si vous voulez sur le santos et de
trinité simplement si c'était la
question de l'offre de médecins à
disposition de la population
le 18 septembre et 2020 et un arrêté du
ministère permettant le recrutement aux
cadres union européenne de médecins ça
tout le monde l'a entendu mais tout le
monde n'a pas été dans le détail je vous
donne tout simple exemple la martinique
avait demandé 0 ophtalmologues vous qui
portez des lunettes vous comprenez tout
de suite on a quand 9 à 12 mois comment
se fait-il que ni le chu ni le privé ni
le public n'a formulé de demande
d'ophtalmologues lawal août c'était 6 la
guyane c'était 8
donc nous avons introduit cette donnée
là et nous allons on dit que c'est
inacceptable et qu'il fallait remédier à
cela nous avons réussi à introduire 6
ophtalmologues actifs qui sont en cours
de recrutement et qui seront recrutés ce
mois ci pour la martinique dont deux
pauvres trinité mais c'est pour le chu
les quatre autres donc on résout ces
problèmes là nous avons ici actes et 16
spécialistes à 10 16 à 17 spécialistes
pour trinité ophtalmologie radiologie
biologie ce cardiologie endocrinologie
gériatre gastro entérologue
anesthésistes urgentiste
pour remédier à ce désert médical qu'il
y a dans le nord à savoir que les
consultations externes spécialisées
doivent être mises à disposition de la
population c'est cet effort général de
nos avancées alors pour conclure une
dernière question qui appelle une
réponse courte puisque le temps qui nous
est imparti est terminée serge haribo
secrétaire général de l'ugtm santé la
grève donc hélas elle continue vous
espérez est-ce que qui aura un terme
dans quelques semaines c'est une affaire
de semaines de mois même si on a compris
que vous êtes encore très volontaire
dans cette lui ce d'autant plus qu'elle
se fait dans un contexte on le sait de
crise sanitaire
ça fait un an qui perdure et que les
personnels de santé
lourd tribut évidemment non cette
migration ya un lourd tribut mais ya une
compréhension avoir nous nous avons dit
dernièrement la rs jeudi dernier nous
entendions avoir en accord pour ce
vendredi qu'il fasse l'effort eux
vendredi là dessus parce que tous les
éléments déjà été discutée nous
attendons des décisions fermes de la rs
et de la direction du chum ça c'est pour
la partie transitoire avant la
reconstruction
concernant la reconstruction nous
attendons cette semaine aussi une
décision ministérielle par le biais du
premier ministre qui nous disent
globalement le volume financier qu'ils
soient mis à disposition non pas de
trinité mais de l'ensemble du tissu
hospitalier en martinique alors il
s'agit du marin de saint-esprit de 3i
les deux marins parasismiques a respecté
ce qu'on appelle un volume de 350 à 400
millions d'euros on peut pas détaillées
rendez vous à la fin de la semaine pour
voir si vous avez donc été entendu merci
serge haribo et puis jimmy bien sûr on
salue l'ensemble des personnels
soignants qui sont sur le front de la
lutte contre eux justement l'épidémie de
covin merci et à bientôt